Arnn: This commencement is here to remind us
why we're here. What do we commence?
The subject of commencement is the good life.
The first graduating classes from
Hillsdale College graduated into a world
of the most disastrous war that our
country has ever known, and the question
is, "What can see them through both these
good times and the bad times that are
both bound to come to everyone in this
audience today?" And the answer is virtue
and faith and freedom and knowledge.
Esolen: Wherever I go the world will be a fallen
one, not because of this or that
political system, though some are much
better than others. It will be a fallen
world because I am in it. Human nature
has not changed. Ideas are actually
rather rare these days. We're full of
ideology but not ideas. Do not give to a
mere idea the love that you owe to
reality and the reverence you owe to God.
In our time at Hillsdale College, we
sought truth and as we graduate and bring
the fruits of our perseverance we live
in a world that has lost sight of truth
in a very fundamental way. We have in
fact come to truth through experience,
through the experience of this community
of truth seekers. The liberal arts
education has made us capable of
understanding something about how the
world works. The more you learn the more
you ought to understand that you have so
much more to learn. Our learning will and can
never come to an end.